greetings everyone and a special hello
sydney do you like scary movies of
course you do even if you don't consider
yourself a horror film aficionado you've
probably seen a scream or at least heard
about what some silly teenagers did last
summer and today on versus tis i your
fearless host mark ellis who will guide
you through a cavalcade of chaotic
killers as two of the biggest thrillers
from the 1990s go head to head or rather
hook to knife in one corner you have the
iconic scream the og film of the
franchise that took an entire
generation's nightmares turned them on
their ear and they reminded us all to
stay virgins as long as possible easier
for some than others in the other corner
it's i know what you did last summer the
film that took a gaggle of teen
heartthrobs and threw some weirdo
fishermen into their road to stardom
don't worry he survived he's fine healed
up and uh he's back to doing what he
loves most often teenagers that hit him
with a car fun fact this is the first
time in the history of versus that our
handsome writer
me had to type a movie title once then
copy and paste it for the rest of the
script have you ever tried to plug that
into a keyboard over and over i know
what you did last summer i might just
give up by round two and call this match
scream versus summer
anyway here's how we'll determine a
winner round one box office round two
tomato meter slash audience score round
three welcome to the jungle round four
smells like teen spirit and then we'll
do a wild card round that i hope can
also be named after a kick-ass rock song
do we go highway to hell for i know you
did last summer or maybe we could do
schools out for scream that also works
for i know you did the last summer you
know what we'll figure it out so let's
just walk this way to round one get it
start me up round one box office before
we get into the box office receipts and
then the critics take and fund rock
tunes i'm gonna be upfront with all of
you freddie prince junior fan club
members as i am your president no one
gets me the way you do
i could seriously text him right now
look i know he did last summer he's
gonna have an uphill climb today scream
is an all-time classic and i-k-w-y-d-l-s
is a well-known property but it's kind
of like scream's little brother now the
good news is that teenagers don't care
what the odds are they believe in
themselves no matter what the stakes or
how many fishermen they might have
killed and that faith might actually pay
off in this round because i know you did
last summer crushed in the fall of 1998
released on october 17th hey that's my
sister's birthday freddy says hi the
film stayed at number one on the
domestic box office charts for three
weeks including the no-brainer halloween
weekend worldwide the film would go on
to scare up
he knew i was going to do it it's just
best to get it over with 125 million
dollars and all of a sudden scream has
its work cut out for it
i am the worst this was a really good
run for writer kevin williamson who
penned both scream and i know you did
last summer and he'd go on to write
scream two which was released a couple
months after i know what you did last
summer and less than a year after screen
mate it's theatrical debut in december
of 1996. wes craven's met a baby would
end up hauling in 172 million dollars
worldwide easily defeating its very game
competitor but speaking of part twos
well look today's matchup is about the
ogs but if you've seen previous episodes
of this show what am i talking about of
course you have you're a huge fan
remember robocop versus terminator or
lethal weapon versus die hard the
franchises as a whole can sometimes
infiltrate the judge's opinion in the
case of megaplex bucks it's not really
going to matter here scream 2
outperformed its predecessor by a total
of 1 million dollars in international
bullion meanwhile i still know we did
last summer manage only a fraction of
the originals take notching 40 million
dollars they killed freddy fritz jr that
one that's not a good move never ever do
that i stand with the audiences i give
props to i know what you did last summer
for arriving first i know i know it was
late to the party and movie forum but it
was actually based off of a 1973 lois
duncan novel ah lois duncan can we get a
round of applause for lois duncan please
don't look behind he was on my high
school freshman reading list and it
really balanced out the book melatonin
that is ethan frome but in the here and
now scream reigned supreme at the box
office numerous times and might again
with the soon to be released part five
ooh i wonder if the hook guy is gonna be
the killer this time cross these
franchises over baby well until that
happens scream gets the win in round one
and goes up one nothing round two tomato
meter slash audience score
said the art house indie cinema to the
big time blockbuster
enjoy your money we'll rely on
professional movie review experts to be
our currency will that be the case with
i know you did last summer going up
against scream i'm not sure what to
expect in terms of tomato meter left for
either picture but i do have high hopes
that the audience score is going to be
fresh in both cases these films were
designed to make pac theaters jump
shriek and ah with delight so let's get
right to the good news that is how the
audience felt about the scream and some
some summertime well they raved about
scream 79 fresh with audiences and no
doubt in part because the film opens by
making us feel like we're taking the
call answered by jiffy pop chef drew
barrymore do you like scary movies of
course we do we're actually watching one
right now and i have to think my movie
trivia showdown experience would have
helped me stay alive in that situation
for a while at least until my parents
got home so moviegoers loved that one
but how did they feel when the girls
stopped by for the summer for the summer
oh boy this one hurts i was ready to
lobby hard for i know what you did last
summer based solely on its audience
score but it's only at 40 what happened
we have rue the best party five cast
member ever sorry nev and the gordon's
fisherman older brother who dropped out
of high school to join a cult and we
can't even get the fresh pouring more
salt in the wound is it scream too again
released weeks after i know you did last
summer got a 57 with audiences but there
is a silver lining scream three is just
at 37
take that ghostface all right well we're
gonna have to hail mary this thing on
the tomato meter if a certain ragtag
group of kids can hit a guy by the side
of the road and almost get away with it
anything's possible and i have good news
the tomato meter score is higher than
the audience score
[Applause]
that was the good news i was telling you
about the bad news is that it's still
rotten at 45 percent
there's no way
oh my god this isn't happening all right
scream time for the death blow
79
fresh on the tomato meter as well as the
audience score how do you like that for
symmetry you shut up just shut up for
funsies let's see them sequels and how
they fared in the tomato patch once
again scream 3 is lower than the og
summer clocking in at just 40 percent
but scream 2 provided the biggest whale
of them all earning 81 fresh scream 4
also eats into fresh territory with an
even 60
while i still know what you did last
summer oh it's uh it's at 7
and i'll always know you did last summer
the classic from 2006 it's at zero
percent
it's not because nobody reviewed it
people reviewed it and it's at zero
percent
i think it's safe to say that as hard as
i lobbied for i kw the summer movie it's
gonna be a win here for scream and it
goes up two to nothing you are not gonna
throw this on me come on guys please
don't do this this isn't getting us
anywhere round three welcome to the
jungle as a great poet once said you
know where you are you're in the jungle
baby
you're gonna die
well those words by robert frost harken
back to the classic rule of the jungle
kill or be killed that could also be the
case with either scream or i know what
you did last summer if you yourself
aren't willing to take a life someone's
probably gonna take yours this round
will take a look at those we lost in
these franchise kicker offers but first
let's enjoy them perpetrators who are
putting in all the elbow grease and
actually murdering folks i know you did
last summer open strong here because our
entire lead cast kills someone it was an
accident or so we think our fab four of
freddie jennifer love sarah michelle and
ryan are being typical dumb teenagers on
a secluded beachside road when thump
uh-oh we're hoping it was just a deer
that ryan's dad's car hit but no only
disney would be aggressive enough to
kill a sweet animal that early in the
movie nope they hit a fisherman who was
then dead but then alive then dead again
then presumably drowned if he was not in
fact dead that second time i said he was
dead but the dude not only wasn't
necessarily deceased he also remembered
and a summer later he put his stellar
handwriting to good use by offing the
same kiddos who almost capped him and of
course he enjoyed some collateral damage
on the way poor johnny galecki his
parents weren't rich and this was before
he had big bang theory cheddar so he was
just a working stiff like the rest of us
and his death is the marker that
fisherman is out for blood and does not
care who gets in his way scream also
opens strong with one of the greatest
and most surprising deaths in film
history drew barrymore originally she
had signed on to play the lead a signing
that convinced wes craven to take
another look at the script that he had
originally passed on directing five
weeks before production was set to begin
drew had an idea colonel pop in her head
hey let's make me the opening act and
subvert audience expectations for the
rest of the movies the gamble works and
if you weren't awake when screen began
all of a sudden you're on the edge of
your seat thereafter okay so we traded
galecki for a barrymore but then
ghostface went on a rampage that saw
even the principal of woodsboro high not
able to fonzerelli his way out of this
film alive ghostface as we now know was
actually two faces billy and stu and
they got even more twisted with their
murdering as the film went on as far as
those lead characters go rose mcgowan's
tatum probably gets the lion's share of
memorable kills she gets tortured
bloodied and garage doored steve didn't
make it to the final credits either nor
did slow runner camera guy kenny but we
weren't all that emotionally invested in
them sarah michelle geller's beauty
pageant winner on the other hand there's
no way she's gonna perish right i mean
we all assumed ryan felipe would die
simply because it was his drunken idiocy
that caused this mess in the first place
as fate would have it he was the first
one to go and poor sarah had to watch it
from stage her character helen shivers
i get it puts up much more of a fight
than her estranged boyfriend and makes
ben willis burn a ton of calories before
her pulse finally stops buffy the
vampire slayer would have handed this
guy his lunch without breaking his sweat
but helen certainly had a horror movie
moral victory at least give her a
participation trophy she survived for
like eight minutes during that chase
both endings leave some room for sequels
but if scream left it to fans to debate
whether matthew willard stu actually
died have fun going down that internet
rabbit hole i know you did last summer
just flat out told us that someone still
has it in for jlh imagine going through
all that rebounding with your sophomore
year in college and then having i still
know show up in the mirror of what is
undoubtedly the steamiest shower in ncaa
history both movies are fun re-watches
because they enjoy their slicing dicing
and icing of famous people but as far as
cast to murdered character ratios go i
know you did last summer comes out on
top of scream here and stays alive to
fight another round way to go lois
duncan it's two to one and we got us a
ball game through art i shall serve my
country
[Applause]
round four smells like teen spirit well
despite what kurt cobain and his rock
and roll music might intimate with the
lights out it's actually much more
dangerous you could trip stub your toe
and if you're in a horror movie the
killer is definitely right there keep
the bulbs on because we have so many
tiger beat pin-ups to enjoy this round
is going to be won by which collective
of high school to college kids is the
better hive of talent and storytelling
if you were a kid in the 1990s this
round is for you i'll give points to
scream for making it fun with courtney
cox from friends and david arquette from
mary and courtney cox but keep in mind
we're only talking about the little
tykes still in school like skeed all
riches billy and matthew lillard's stew
they weren't well known beforehand but
scream certainly changed that within a
few weeks rose mcgowan had done a film
called the doom generation after she
debuted in some movie called encino
she was in encino man the paul shore
classic oh that's instant credit in my
book but she was still auditioning to
get into the new thriller picture going
around town but her savviness was beyond
her years she knew that brunette was
playing the lead so at her audition
where she also had brown hair she asked
the casting director who was blonde who
their hairdresser is because she planned
on going blonde the next day the gamble
worked and rose landed the role of tatum
meanwhile in that port town of i know
what you did last summer ryan philippe
was considered for the role of barry
after being suggested by his real-life
gf reese witherspoon she decided to not
play the lead role of julie james but
did mention that ryan would be good for
barry as for sarah michelle geller her
star-making turn of buffy the dracula
hater and i know you did last summer
both happened in 1997 and as an
on-screen couple the pair made the
perfect foil for the decidedly goody
two-shoes leads of freddy prince jr's
rey and jennifer love hewitt's julie
despite what should have been considered
for an emmy freddie's role as tough guy
in an episode of family matters didn't
move the needle and the she's all that's
in summer catches of the world didn't
happen until after the events of last
summer jennifer love he was rocking it
on party of five and was the first major
casting decision of the film director
jim gillespie had to fight to get prince
jr in there the studio said nae multiple
times before a new look diet and gym
sanctioned body convinced the brass to
change their minds did someone say party
of five
i did nev campbell also starred in the
seminal mid-90s drama that only cast
dudes with animals his last names scott
wolf and a pre-dharma initiative matthew
fox both worked alongside jen and nev so
if they're the two biggest stars heading
into this movie is this whole round
maybe match gonna come down to who was
better on party five
full disclosure i never watched the show
i was too busy with friends hi monica
but i'll tell you this julie james has
the most sound moral compass of anyone
in her movie and she's even resourceful
enough to track down hillbilly and hesh
to find answers about the guy she
thought she killed who's now actually
killing her friends but she also falls
for that old trick of cornering yourself
into an unwinnable situation at the
behest of a rando fisherman she runs
onto his boat during the movie's climax
maybe to call the police but you could
have done that from the shore too right
come on jules how did you even get into
college in the first place nev campbell
city prescott would never fall for such
a trick because jaime kennedy's randy
made sure his gang knew all the rules of
scary cinema don't you know the rules
what rules kennedy is the x factor in
this round and not just because he had a
prank show called that for years
randy is part comic relief part
shakespearean chorus he's letting us the
audience know what to prepare for and
most of his slasher rules end up working
out as he said they would possibly with
a few twists and turns on the way and
number three never ever ever under any
circumstances say i'll be right back
because she won't be back i'm getting
another beer you want one
yeah sure i'll be right back
but if you really did want this whole
round to come down to party of five fine
nev campbell was featured in all 142
episodes of that show jennifer love
hewitt ooh just a hundred even look i
love you and you're crushing it on 9-1-1
but the teenagers in scream get the
point in round four and thus they take
the match
but i am a man of my word and you were
promised one more round here we go and
now it's time for the wild card round
time is on my side well certainly is for
the rolling stones and as the years
since the late 90s would indicate both
scream and i know you did last summer
have left considerable legacies starting
with the sequels to those originals
scream 2 might be even more heralded
than the og in some circles and scream 5
inexplicably not called 5 cream is set
to release within weeks i still know and
i'll always know may have faltered with
the box office
and with the critics and with audiences
but that franchise has staying power and
the summer regrets ain't done yet
because it's now a streaming series on
amazon and season one went so well that
we're on to season two you wanna know
who did it okay i'm gonna say is that at
the end of season one dylan is in jail
which cements dylan as an all-time cool
kid name it worked on 90210 and it's
still working today that and zachary are
the best possible names for a boy but we
can also agree mark is a timeless
moniker and technically that whole i
know you did last summer lineage has
lasted 23 years longer than scream
thanks to the original novel but whereas
scream had a late start wow did it
tortoise its way past the hair in a
hurry the film quickly became iconic for
its meta insights into horror canon the
winking sense of humor and the sheer
amount of unpredictability within the
plot plus it had an even longer tv run
than the summertime kids so far as a
show of the same name was an mtv staple
from 2015 to 2019
upon re-watching because i do hard work
here scream still holds up in every way
imaginable the utes feeling
indestructible the puppy love of high
school romances and news media
sensationalizing true crime i know you
did last summer it's a good reminder to
not drink and drive and to not associate
with trust fund douches because they
really don't have your best interest at
heart and if any of you are still
planning on going hiking in a rain
slicker at midnight
bring a hook you'll need it the
following summer i know what you did
last summer holds up primarily as an
enjoyable product of its time that
stands severed head and shoulders
amongst most slashers of its era but
scream is a movie and a franchise for
all times countless films were inspired
by it and i can't wait to get back into
a movie theater to see stab or scream or
five cream whatever you want to call it
i just want to see how it's going to
surprise me again after all these years
scream wins the round and is now just
running up the score and hopes the
college football playoff committee is
paying attention and never ever
under any circumstances known to god
speak about this again
is that clear
it is not merely a future therapy bill
agreed
okay scream one in a cakewalk but i know
you did last summer did enough for me to
make some weekend plans i'm gonna watch
i still know that super twist ending was
ahead of its time before the mcu gave us
like 17 post credit scenes per flick and
horror movie icons winked at us that
they might not be dead i know you did
last summer closed on one more super
suspenseful sequence that still holds up
you heard it here first we would not see
sam jackson as nick fury and iron man
unless i know what you did last summer
paved the way that's probably a very hot
take as was this whole show but it's
just my opinion now let your voice be
heard hit me up on social media at mark
ellis live and cast your vote for the
best horror film between 1996 and 1997.
was leprechaun on the moon made then
might have to rethink this entire
episode also check back here for more
movie insights from rotten tomatoes
until next time this has been versus i'm
mark ellis and i'll be right back
you